the red turtle was a co-production
between Wild Bunch and Studio Ghibli my
favorite animation studio of all time so
naturally I was interested in seeing
this film I could have seen it at AFI
Fest but all of the showings were either
at the exact same time that lala land
was showing or the exact same time that
Patterson was showing so unfortunately I
missed it because those two films were a
higher priority for me it took forever
to get here for some reason despite the
fact that it was nominated for Best
Animated Feature at the Oscars this year
this is a film about a castaway who
washes up on the shore of a deserted
island and attempts to survive at least
that's the first act he makes raps he
tries to get out of there he seems to be
very handy you don't know really
anything about him at all beyond the
fact that he was in a small boat and he
washed up on the island and now he's
just there what is he going to do
how is it going to survive as he makes
these rafts and tries to escape some
unseen force keeps halting him from
doing that keeps destroying the raft
from underneath him and eventually he
learns that a very large red turtle is
the culprit and I'm not going to get
into much else beyond that some very
interesting twists and turns happen
after that and the entire film for the
most part is completely free of dialog
there's a few times where somebody goes
hey and tries to figure out if you know
there's anybody else on this island but
there's no dialogue in this movie it's
entirely told through visual
storytelling which is something that I
love I don't take enough directors
working today utilize visual
storytelling Spielberg does it quite a
bit
Kubrick did it quite a bit directors who
are able to communicate exactly what
they want to to the audience with no one
saying anything entirely through the
emotion on the characters faces or
through the way shots are edited
together and that's one of the things I
absolutely adore about the red turtle
this movie is nothing but visual
storytelling you're meant to feel every
emotion this guy is feeling just through
the way his face looks and through the
way the shots are constructed and this
is a beautiful looking movie especially
the backgrounds there's an incredible
looking bamboo forest that really stands
out the color green in this movie just
explodes I mean this is a visually
stunning film
is at times though a little hard to get
invested in because it entirely relies
on that visual storytelling and we're so
used to seeing films where you are
learning things about characters you're
feeling their emotions you're getting
into their lives and you have
interesting dialogue along the way but
in this film you don't have that at all
gracefully it's only 80 minutes long and
I think if it was any longer than that
it would have outstayed its welcome
because there are moments in this movie
where you feel like you're watching any
long gated short film that's extremely
well directed and gorgeously animated
and has some very interesting subtext to
say about life and the process of life
just explored in a very unique and
different way and that's one of the
things I do also love about this movie
is its exploration of the ups and downs
of life what can come with life the
hardships of it the trials and the
tribulations all in a very short time
and told entirely through visual
storytelling so you're able to feel a
lot of emotion just from that which is
really something to be praised I don't
think it's as good as some of the other
films in the animated category like Kubo
and the two strings Moana Zootopia and I
don't think it's as good as your name
which was my favorite animation of last
year which wasn't even nominated I also
think the boy and the beast is a better
animated films in the red turtle the red
turtle is a gorgeous movie beautifully
animated with a lot of really cool
things to say in a very different way
with no real answers it's a very
ambiguous film that's in a way almost a
love letter to nature even the filmmaker
himself has said nature with a capital n
it's a direct quote is what he was
trying to tribute in this movie the feel
of that euphoria you get when you truly
see something beautiful and in nature
and the way it can affect you and the
way it affects your life and I think
it's a gorgeous movie I do think that
from a substance standpoint the film is
a little weak though I'm going to give
the red turtle of B
guys thank you so much as always for
watching this week is going to be insane
with reviews I have a lot of really cool
things coming to some very early reviews
I'm excited about that I can't wait to
bring to you I also have my x-men
origins Wolverine hilarious aadhi coming
tomorrow with my buddy to flick dick
look forward to that you guys are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching what did you think of that
Oscars Best Picture confusion that was
insanity
I had an Oscar party last night we went
nuts we just we went nuts I have never
seen that in my life that was crazy what
are your thoughts on that
what's your favorite animated film of
last year thank you so much guys for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck my knives
[Applause]
[Music]